there is a post-credits scene this is an
Avengers type of post-credit scene which
would be really cool let's talk to his
credit scene okay I'm very I'm very
interested as well because we read in
the subtitles no not the American please
tell me that the American is hopper I
have no idea I have no idea you know I I
mean that of course in my old do it
seems seems pretty crazy though I mean
that that machine went off and you know
blew up the hopper seemed to be trapped
there he did glance around a little bit
but he seemed to be trapped and the
Machine exploded and you mean what would
why would you cut to what is it what is
it starts with a K or something some
town in Russia right where there's some
American and there's some other prisoner
I'm talking a full-on Russian invasion
right here in Hawkins I don't know I
mean it just seemed strange I don't know
how though it does seem strange that's
it that's a good word guess what I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it are you
ready for it I've seen stranger things
I'm such a jerk are you talking about we
had our very first stranger things
post-credit scene when you watch that
you found out that the duffer brothers
included that this year what was your
reaction well I think Marvel does that
too is it's really cool they're like
they take inspiration from a lot of
really cool people and they put it in
their show and they do a good job so
good for them I mean I hope David isn't
art David Hopper isn't fully gone but I
feel like he'll be coming back I don't
think he's he's gone forever you agree
with me about that right I know that you
are the one who was away with the duffer
brothers you got them to tell you things
what have they told you about season
four nothing they really have it theirs
though like actually this weekend I'm
trying to sit down with them to like
talk about what's going on because we
didn't get a chance we all ran off after
the shooting and I
you know we haven't seen each other for
a long time and I was like guys let's
sit down and I actually was like before
this tonight let's sit down they were
like oh yeah man we can't we got a thing
we got to make up they've been like
dodging me they've been dodging me for
days hopper here what do you go so I
know nothing I know as much as you I've
seen the final episode it's
extraordinary it's magnificent
what hopper does and what happens to him
he acts like the person that he's meant
to be and then there is this mystery at
the end I don't really know what's gonna
happen but if you find out from the
doubler brothers please let me know well
but have them return my calls god I
really hate to do this but I gotta run
soon emergency can we hold on to hope
we're still out there should always hold
on to hope we should never let go of
hope but barb is really dead
are you serious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]